good morning believe nation today's
message is do extraordinary over to you
Bear Grylls and it was something I was
told on the first day of ever joining
the Special Forces and I remember the
end of this long selection process where
180 of us had been whittled down to four
of us and this guy who had never seen
before came in stood in front of us and
said this the difference between
ordinary and extraordinary is often just
that little word extra and the work I'm
going to now ask you to do is not gonna
be ordinary it's going to be
extraordinary but what's going to make
the difference is we're not one ounce of
youth thinks you can you're the people
who over this last year have shown me
you can turn around and give me that
little bit extra and it's that that's
gonna make your work here extraordinary
to me extraordinary is do you settle for
good enough or not I think in general in
life we tend to settle for good there's
the book with the great that talks about
the enemy of great
is good the enemy of great isn't
terrible because if something is really
terrible you're gonna fix it but if
something is good then you let it slide
you let it go through you know it could
be better but you like yeah just it's
good it's good enough let's put it
through and that's how too many people
live their lives they've settled for a
good life instead of going for a great
one instead of going for an
extraordinary one and so you can apply
it to the work you're doing today you
can apply it to the videos you're making
you can apply it to your relationship at
home with your wife with your husband
with your kids with your friends with
your parents with the customers you're
going to call tomorrow you can apply to
everything that you do do you settle for
good or do you try to go that little bit
extra to make it extraordinary I think
about the example the
to set video that we made and I told the
story a couple times but I think it
really resonates here where my team
spent a lot of time making a video 50
Cent's top ten rules of success and I
watched it and it was it was good it was
a good video I liked it but I felt it
could be better
I felt 50 had more in him that we hadn't
uncovered that we should be able to find
and share and so then I spent extra
hours of my time putting together the
research to make it happen that I was
doing the job of somebody on my team
because I thought it could be better I
didn't want to settle for having just a
good enough video and so it took a ton
of man-hours with this video together
and when we launched it I had success
and somehow I got the 50 cent I don't
know 50 cent but he saw it he liked it
he shared it he wrote a blog post about
it and he tweeted it and I think he put
on this Facebook he shared it now would
the first video have gotten to him and
would he have shared it maybe the one
that was just good enough maybe but he
saw something extraordinary that he
loved and he wanted to share it and that
often is what makes a difference and you
know you know when the thing you made
was just good enough you know when
you're just skating by and you know when
you put everything you had into making
this next thing that you're doing
amazing I want you to be proud of the
work that you're doing I want you to be
able to show something that you made
every day to want to give it to your
grandkids I want my grandkids to watch
these videos and first say how young I
looked and then say man you really
poured a lot of energy and love into it
we're proud of you and I want them to be
inspired and learn from it and it
doesn't mean that I'm not still gonna
get better what's extraordinary for me
now won't be in a couple years my best
thing two years ago pales in comparison
to what I can do now because I've worked
harder I've learned I built my muscles
I'm better and I still strive to get
better and better and better there is no
perfection it's only something that we
strive for so it encouraged you to stop
settling for good enough look at what
you've done today it depends on what
time you're watching this video look at
what is on the schedule for today and
don't go to sleep tonight until you can
say that you did something that was
extraordinary so the question today
today is I'm curious what have you done
today that's extraordinary or what are
you going to do that's extraordinary
where you
not settle for just being good enough
leave it down the comments below super
curious to find out what you have to say
I also want to give a quick shout out to
William young William thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word it really really really means a
lot to me and I hope you're enjoying the
read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you guys again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso you know
when you're chasing your dream and when
you're when you're working hard chasing
something you love and I'm completely
dedicated it just it just happens you
don't you don't you can't really note
notice it you know even still to this
day I'm in an amazing position in my
life but I'm still I'm still working
like I'm not I'm still working like I'm
not in this position absolutely I'm
still working like none of this is even
yeah I mean yeah yeah it's just it's
just something I love to do and I just
keep pushing I keep working hard I can't
pinpoint an exact moment for you but yep
if anything I always felt like it was
happening way back then and now what is
happening but now I almost feel like
it's not happening I mean I want to push
to to something else absolutely I'm
always striving to push forward the idea
something that no one else can believe
it you can believe in God gives you this
vision he gave to you and through alone
you have to carry a cross for a little
bit on your own people will watch you
first they'll cheer and they'll be upset
with you then they'll get real mad
you're doing a couch then you get off
the couch and you
this hero it's impossible if God gave me
that vision for you to fail at it must
be quick so they said very important
nothing because in fact in every
business everybody quits all the time
the success story the ones who went the
extra mile you can be asking for
assignments that are above your level so
there's work that you do at your level
and then there's work that you do above
your level and the only way that you're
going to be promoted to do work above
your level is a if you can demonstrate
that you're capable of doing the work at
your level and be if you are proactive
in seeking out opportunities that expand
your capability and give you a give you
a chance to work above the level that
you're at nothing's going to happen
unless you take that initial action
nothing's going to happen nothing's
going to change unless you put down that
pen in the meeting and you sit up and
you pay attention and you listen for
your opportunity to speak nothing's
going to happen unless you push yourself
to go in and make the ask for that
assignment that scares you to death